foreign
[Music]
what what I'm not sure which is more
sinnable that this life preserver jumped
all the way from being attached to the
hull of the ship so the doctor could
easily identify it or that they would
still have buoyancy-based life
preservers in space might as well send
both I guess this suspicious look is
hilarious if you know the doctor's
history with angels but what if you
don't whose Reliance on Easter eggs in
its vast history is both one of its
greatest strengths and greatest
weaknesses plus the Callback happened so
fast blink and you'll miss it you know
what suspiciously absent from the
outside of this ship life preservers
watching television through window
blinds my name is Max
obvious villain is obvious evening
passenger 57 terrible memory taking
Wesley snipe's name in vain Titanic
um it's over the name information sin
these Angels starting every answer with
information is as pointless as it is
annoying which is very
is chosen as the most famous vessel of
the planet Earth somewhere on the planet
below the Batmobile weeps silently
plotting its revenge alongside a
DeLorean in the Oscar Mayer Wienermobile
all designations are chosen by Mr Max
Capricorn
presidents
the max stands for maximum villain and
maximum overacting you don't quite work
a cruise on your own you're not with
anyone relationship pressure also on a
night like this perhaps she thinks he
should find love at first sight by just
spinning around and looking at all the
lovers dancing if not just breathe and
confide in me I believe in you and can't
get you out of my head after all better
the devil you know dang it say something
I just want to say that if you lead with
your tongue like this you deserve
whatever horrible things befall you
for that box talking with your mouth
open I mean eating with your mouth full
I mean whatever this guy is doing
swallow your food man
[Music]
extending your Sonic Screwdriver without
explicit consent
I don't understand how anyone could make
the leap that this man would be
magically responsible for the premature
champagnulation
[Applause]
and we like you super glad you both
survived to live Beautiful lives beyond
being defined by your size and
appearance they cut a Metroid shower
Portside
the except meteors don't have trails in
space they only have them when breaking
through the atmosphere comets do because
they're made of ice but you distinctly
said meteor so my um actually ink stance
now human beings Worship the Great God
Santa creature with fears and Claws
right because your civilization knows
enough about Earth to create a replica
of the Titanic but not enough to
understand who Santa was got it go to
the country or accept me
and her majesty And the reporter please
don't forget him can we see some of his
unnecessary backstory please I mean
thank the time Lord Almighty that this
computer system showed immediate danger
rather than the menu during tonight's
entertainment or detailed status of each
toilet flush you got me towards coming
in and no shielding right can you
imagine not using your masks I mean
Shields not everything is a metaphor for
the pandemic not everything is a
metaphor for the pandemic not everything
is a here's the thing about this show I
have no idea if this is meant to be a
flaming asteroid chunk flinging through
the window or if it's just a moist alien
turd pellet and that is ultimately one
of the reasons I find it hard to
recommend this show doing Max Capricorn
this insanely over edited portion of the
program is brought to you by forceful
foreshadowing and straight up Bonkers
riding fueled by cocaine Zoom close up
zoom zoom close up zoom zoom extreme
close-up zoom zoom close up zoom zoom
zoom excitement this incoherently
explodes on for some time that's a lot
of damage and debris but you know what I
don't see floating around anywhere life
preserversion yeah pretty bad taste
right maybe similar to making a Cheesy
lighthearted sci-fi romp based on a real
event where thousands of people lost
their lives looking forward to the
Doctor Who Christmas specials based
around Pearl Harbor 911 and the
Challenger disaster in a few years
kitchen Shield stabilized Doctor Who
screwdriver saves the day so much it
might as well be named the Deus Ex
Sonica just stay still all of you I need
to get a headcount for our discount
Poseidon Adventure group Kylie professor
in the plums Darth small guy who's
somehow even more of a butthole than
Billy Zane okay I think we're ready I
will get you out of here straight I
promise
look at me I'm
empty promises trouble is why don't you
set a drift is programmed to lock onto
the nearest center of gravity as opposed
to locking onto something more practical
like oh I don't know it's owner also a
good thing that Earth only has one tiny
landmass for the discount Bill and Ted
phone booth thing to gravitate towards
can you imagine the trouble of locating
it if Earth had a lot of land or water
huh you really lucked out there
information we now have only one
function and what's that information to
kill sin formation and to do it in the
slowest and most dramatic and Abstract
way as possible
neat so whose idea was it to propel a
massive ship with a nuclear bomb because
those people deserve a solid Senate I'm
903 years old and I'm the man who's
gonna save your lives and all six
billion people on the planet below false
confidence
we could do robotics both of us of
course you can also I love how this show
thinks we need to know more backstory to
support any level of shenanigans nobody
cares about why you can do robotics it's
not like we have to stretch very far to
believe any of this Insanity they're on
the [ __ ] Titanic with a nuclear bomb
nobody gives a [ __ ] about how you know
anything about robots
so I'm gonna get through that that's
racist
you know what this show gets right
trolling people here we are believing
that these Precious Moments are
meaningful when in reality these two die
but we are probably meant to be okay
with it because they were severely in
debt five thousand credits
spent 5 000 credits don't like me a long
skip hey you will tell me the point of
and he does because the plot needs him
too but doesn't this mean you could just
stall the robot by continuing to ask it
pointless questions you really only need
your basic five-year-old and you're good
to go but that's not the only problem
you'd think this would be the moment to
tell the doctor that you've been shot
and are slowly bleeding to death but no
you might be a time King from Gabby but
he's done it to it and so the party
takes a short rest to restore some hit
points spell slots and develop a sense
of camaraderie because the show somehow
has time for this must be well passed
Maybe
assuming your home time zone is Earth
time
applied to the company
to get the job even more backstory but
this time with fiery console mood
lighting mixed with the scent of charred
Rubber and imminent death I'm pretty
sure the show thinks it's building
empathy for its characters but I'm
actually actively rooting for their
death now how come you know it so well
I was sort of um
a few years ago sort of made
well sort of homes and um
I'm an old man well I won't survive 10
years no I don't know there's some
powerful Shenanigans going on with the
wound hopping from one side of your head
to the other so half hope perhaps your
newfound magic abilities will keep you
alive in prison
and despite all logic so have you why
aren't you getting off the rickety
Bridge there's a lot the tradition it's
a Christmas the angels have wings you
said holy [ __ ] we're going to die wrong
information but only after making your
overly dramatic cheaply produced and
vaguely sacrilegious entrance and giving
your targets plenty of time to arm
themselves they were having trouble with
crawling across this but now they have
the balance to stand up while swinging
violently can we just agree all these
idiots should be dead by now
[Music]
you knew you could do this the whole
time but waited until now bonak off a
lot of dick is more like it also it's
super good that no other Machinery
inside the EMP blast radius was
negatively affected
amp transmitter
he wanted to use and it can still be
recharged even though he can't it's
easily accessible and completely
removable for maximum convenience
uh 21 4 5 6 7 8. this eventually Works
information protocol grants you only
three questions these three questions
have been used well that's a very random
and plot specific protocol to have in
place apparently the host went to the
Monty Python in the search for the Holy
Grail Bridge of Death Bridge Keepers
School of numbering questions you're
coming with me yeah that seems like the
only reasonable option here carry on
Brixton take this interesting you're do
thingy to an [ __ ]
foreign
still with us indeed he is no matter
where you are in the ship always
available at the push of a button that
just happens to be right beside you
really kind of amazing when you think
about it there's an old traditional
palette star
what the [ __ ] sort of tradition are we
talking about here before one leaves a
stranger to his certain death stand on a
first aid box and snog a bit one thing I
love about this scene is that the doctor
suddenly has full confidence to race
across a now not so rickety Bridge power
of boners man it changes things this is
where the kitchen staff were murdered
earlier so there are far too few
carcasses in this room it's time we did
something to help him but also time to
send that SOS maybe also do that before
teleporting so you know everyone else
can be saved my name is Max
oh oh I'm I'm sorry was this reveal
meant to be exciting be interesting
notable
[Music]
Mr Capricorn I resigned
she's driving a forklift across an
entire room at forklift speed and no one
does anything to stop her and then they
just push against each other for a while
like I'm watching Battle Bots
and then one host throws one Halo and it
just happens to cut a brake line so she
has to sacrifice her life
oh the show man and here is where she
decides to save herself by jumping out
of the slowly moving forklift and
letting the momentum take the bad guy to
his death no another pointless sacrifice
cool get a new special effect episode
you've now pulled this exact trick one
two three four different times I suppose
this is as good time as any to point out
that not a single woman survived this
Voyage this giant piece of concrete
bounces off Mr Jerk Face's skull like
it's nothing which just proves that
they're all wearing hard hats that have
been made up to look like their actual
heads it's a pretty impressive makeup
job actually this lasts for a full
minute you guys so he has control of
them now but how why when what where
they devote to the next highest
Authority and that's me oh who also how
is the next highest Authority him and
not the person piloting the ship from
the helm these robots think the person
with authority aboard the ship is the
illegal stowaway that doesn't even exist
in the Manifest I mean Bravo this is
just dumb as hell but they really do
sell out for it
still more historically accurate than
the Crown though
of kissing dead people but if you could
choose don't care if you could decide
who lives and who died
that would make you a monster I want
them all dead consider me the worst
monster of them all I just want to point
out that this machine is not only in
terrible shape with its insides on the
outside but moments ago it didn't have
enough juice to bring back Astrid
however now it will work perfectly when
the doctor and sad old man need to
teleport away and what about me I travel
alone unless you're Kylie Minogue
apparently which in case All Aboard it's
oils planet Earth now that's a
retirement plan
oh hey sorry is this thing still going I
swear I thought it ended about 15
minutes ago
if you've ever wanted to know what it's
like to probe into the back end of
cinema sins and learn our deepest
darkest Secrets Behind The Sims podcast
is just what you need each week writers
Aaron that's me today that's me and
Jonathan yep discuss what it takes to
create the content that you enjoy on
YouTube hopefully enjoy they probably do
I mean even if they don't we talk about
it that's true I guess I'll just wrap
this up real quick and let you know that
you can listen to behind the scenes here
on YouTube or if search for the show on
your favorite podcast player yep coming
at me live from Boston Paradise
[Music]
bun down
[Music]
she's three years old and I'm getting
too old for this
information stop
stop
Ava I said stop he saved Our Lives we
are entirely grateful he asks each
traveler five questions three questions
cool guys don't look at explosions they
blow things up and then walk away
my shoulder angel don't listen to that
guy he's trying to lead you down the
path of righteousness I'm gonna lead you
down the path that rocks I'm a
professional doctor you saw me you don't
remember
you're not falling yesterday
[Music]
lying